we are more than a year into this
pandemic looks like we're coming out the
other side
knock wood and everything's going to be
uh i think much better
but everybody in our business who
performs for a living
in front of an audience we've all been
thinking
when when can we get back to performing
again and what's it going to be like
when we get in front of an audience
you very recently figured out a way to
go on stage where was this was this in
tennessee it was in nashville yeah he
was in nashville
and you recorded a stand-up set in front
of an audience
and this was just how long ago like a
couple weeks ago a couple weeks ago yeah
yeah and first of all uh
that had to be very strange after not
being in front of an audience
for over a year to suddenly be back was
that scary were you afraid
well i wasn't nervous about that
until right before my intro but because
i was like dude why would you record a
combi album you ain't been up in a year
and a half
are you crazy but at the same time i've
done sets like you know if
say fans i was shooting a movie for a
while and i go back on the road
those first sets would be so like my
favorite sets
because i'm just i'm just going i'm just
whatever's on my mind it's
it's usually very raw and what and this
is why i think honestly it's probably my
best work
actually that i've ever recorded uh but
it was it was
it was a little nervous just being in
front of people yeah but then at the
same time like i wore like i've wore a
suit i've never purposely wore a suit on
stage before
in my whole career for on purpose and to
actually like you know someone throw a
suit on and
the audience energy was it felt like
they were just so happy to be
entertained again
i think tommy's going to be great for us
that's what i'm
kind of hoping for and i think could be
really nice is i keep thinking
there could be a really nice moment
coming in
comedy music theater across the board
anything where there's an audience
because i think people are so hungry for
it
that i imagine you coming out and doing
a show you always get laughs but then
there's going to be this added energy of
oh my god we get to be in an audience
again
and that's got to be nice to feel that
love that love and that com
like and i've said this on stage too i'm
like yo y'all actually are my friends at
this point cause i haven't
talked to nobody for real and personally
about any of the stuff i'm talking about
right so it's like yeah basically are my
friends now and that's what it felt like
it felt like
a audience full of people because people
just haven't been around each other and
yeah
comedy is going to be a very because i
think now people if they're going to pay
to do
anything or leave the house they're like
no i better be entertained
like you're not going to be going to a
club just to be standing around looking
at people you're going to like want to
go somewhere where
you're actually entertained and i think
comedy because we actually
you know we make a lot of these subjects
comfortable yeah and i think
that's the ex i'm telling you the
audience was so good
um and i just did an hour and a half i'm
just like
i felt like i blacked out on stage and
just went there and then when i listened
to it again recently because i'm doing
all the editing and stuff now it's like
yo this is this is probably my best work
but it's really honest
when can we uh when can we hear that
comedy out i think i'm gonna probably
release it
after either in between free guy
which comes out august 13th and
another film man but i guess i can't
tell nobody yeah let me ask you about
this other film you're not allowed to
talk about
that's my job space jam
sequel yeah okay you're not allowed to
say
anything about this but um
i know that you're somehow involved am i
allowed to say that
okay uh people are very excited
sir don't make me take my exhibits out
again sure
this is not you in the car i have a
photograph
of you are you in fact a bad [ __ ]
damn right i am so you can't
that must be frustrating i'm just going
to say you don't have to say anything i
think it'd be very frustrating
let's say you were in the space jam
sequel i'm not saying you
are but let's say you were and people
are so excited about that and you're not
allowed to tell people about it i'd be
going crazy
i mean if by chance i'm in that
particular film it's it is weird to not
be able to be like you know
seeing the trailer do well and all this
stuff and you can't be like
i'm a part of that but allegedly if i
was a part of if you were a part of part
of it yeah
if you were particularly frustrated i
guess there's no way we'll ever know
if you're part of this like it's not
coming out july
uh bad trip is now streaming on netflix
and uh little rel may or may not
be in the upcoming space jam sequel
we'll never
ever know
you